The Canadian province of Alberta is waiting
for immigrants
who are ready to settle in small and rural towns
with a population of fewer than 100,000 people.
This year, the region launched
two immigration programs to such areas,
one for skilled workers
and the other one for entrepreneurs,
but the exact list of towns that are suitable
for moving appeared only in October.
For skilled workers,
twenty two towns were selected,
and in one of them
candidates must find a job to apply for immigration.
For entrepreneurs
who want to start a business,
37 towns are suitable.
The list of towns
and information on the programs is on our website
end.immigrant dot
Today subscribe
and don't miss your opportunity to move to Canada.